l'élection présidentielle dès 2022
je soutiendrai le président de la
république
je pense j'espère qu'il sera candidat
pendant trois ans à matignon j'ai
approché beaucoup plus que ça n'avait
été le cas dans tout le reste de ma vie
la présidence de la république et le
président la république
et j'ai vu combien cette mission ce
mandat a été incroyablement difficile et
je pense que emmanuel macron effet d'un
métal
dont je ne vois pas beaucoup la trace
dans tous ceux qui sont candidats
aujourd'hui à l'élection présidentielle
et je pense que c'est
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un cadeau pour toi je t'offre un
week-end n'ont point au chocolat un
détail week-end détente et massage où tu
veux avec ton mari j'aimerais mieux de
détartrage non mes danseurs et
détente et massages avec ton mari était
chaude ou pas c'est pour moi c'est
cadeau
sur les gens c'est de la merde
j'en ai eu la turbo est le voyage est
long mois
d'attenté massage pour toi aussi aimé
merci c'est pour une personne ou pour 2
bat mais deux personnes sur moi pour
mazères ii
[Rires]
pour 3 mai 3 3 mais 4 du coup
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau c'est bon
vous avez donc edouard philippe élite et
sur cette amitié reçoit l'ès 1 ça a bien
marché ou pas les audiences ces
audiences dans la moyenne et il ya une
phrase à retenir c'est tout vient à
point c'est ce qu'il a dit quand ils
font part d'une candidature à la
présidentielle qui sera pas grandie
dornan 22 mai sans doute en 2000 ans de
sa vie à regarder c'est ce qu'il a dit
là regarde ouais j'aime bien être en
effet celui qui participe à la prise de
décision ou celui qui prend les
décisions est ce qu'un jour j'aurai
l'occasion de servir mon pays dans la
politique nationale peut-être si c'est
le cas j'en très heureux et une chose
que je sais c'est que quand on veut
servir son pays il n'est pas inutile de
s'y préparer avant d'essayer de donner
le meilleur de soi même ça me paraît
indispensable
donc vous vous laisser du temps
où il fut pas du tout un homme
impatient
je pense que les choses deviennent
toutes choses bien ta points
voilà qui est quand même bien placé
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas
fait un arrangement avec emmanuel macron
c'est à dire tu te présentes pas en 2022
et après tu as sont comme moi je
pourrais plus me présenter ce sera toi
en 2027 je ne suis pas dans le secret
des dieux malgré ce que vous laissez
entendre dimanche
que je peux dire c'est que edouard
philippe était un homme extrêmement
correct il a il est très fidèle à
emmanuel macron ils s'entendent très
bien et que de toute façon il est vrai
que pour se préparer une présidentielle
il faut vraiment se préparer longtemps à
l'avancé au revoir un peu tout ce qui se
passe donc il a raison elle est très
sage et magna s'est réuni il a été
conseiller des années à l'elysée non
l'été comme il aurait peut-être
n'ont-ils voir clip il admire les
premiers ministres non mais là même
jamais envisagé je sais qu'il ya eu
toute une
demers qui le voulaient de soutenir à la
présidence à la présidentielle en tout
cas ne le fait pas mais en revanche
effectivement on va le retrouver après
macron puisque les mandats c'est deux
fois deux voies alors le dropt a tracé
un peu con qu'on en a l'air vous me
posez une question je vous réponds je
vous dis oui kelly bas on sait à quel
point les politiques peuvent être des
escrocs et des mythos et ben moi pour le
coup j'ai été passionné par cette
interview je les trouvais honnête j'ai
trouvé loyal je les trouvais enfin je me
suis dit en fait c'est lui que
j'aimerais avoir un président et sa
barbe bicolore je le trouve à trans face
à laurent attendrissant convoi qui c'est
qui est mort il a été à fond dans ses
projets qui a été à fond pour la france
et moi je trouve ça génial et j'ai envie
que ce soit lui président baba ne sera
pas pour tout de suite
pour l'instant ça y est c'est anne
hidalgo qui s'est présentée on a un
marine le pen qui s'est présentée n'a
pas encore eric zemmour on a indiqué
bertrand valérie pécresse voilà pour
l'instant vous avez le choix entre ça et
après on verra ces gens ne pensent qu'à
eux entre lui qui est en train
effectivement d'avoir un deal avec ma
grosse cette fois ci pour être pour y
être mais si maîtresse qui se présente
pourquoi pour affaiblir bertrand et pour
pouvoir avoir un peu de ministres avec
macron ces gens c'est hallucinant ils
vont juste là où il ya le pouvoir il a
envoyé plus en rien en tous les cas la
politique pas beaucoup pécresse a là
aucune chance d'être élue elle sait très
bien tout ce qu'elle réussit au
ministère schéma elle a des chances
d'être élu alors qu'elle passa primaire
et c'est comme tout le monde va pas
arrêter moncigale cher mais pas du tout
hein elle va falloir y aller
ces gains précédents
alors al'inverse comme l'a dit kelly moi
je trouve que c'est un exercice
extrêmement bien réussie en terme de
marketing pur qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec ce qu avec ce qu'a dit
edouard philippe c'est je pense que pour
tous les hommes et les femmes politiques
qui vont qui veulent se présenter c'est
à écouter et à regarder parce qu'il est
allé sur tous les terrains il est allé
sur l'humain quand on lui a demandé son
pire moment et là il a parlé d'un sujet
qui étais tu m'as de père de famille un
père de famille avec des enfants qui
malheureusement sont décédés quand il
sait s'il s'est agi de loyauté on dit
toujours que les politiques mais des
couteaux dans le dos etc il a dit il n'y
a pas une feuille de papier à cigarette
entre le président et moi et c'est donc
il est tombé dans aucun piège en termes
de marketing salariés des c'était
extrêmement réussie alors alors il est
revenu aussi c'est un feuilleton de sa
barbe il ya aussi la famille jamais
revenu c'est le feuilleton du
quinquennat la barbe c'est la rajeunit
alors regardez et ben il en a marre les
aussi influent prochain il a dit que
c'était pas dû au stress
illégaux
quand j arrive j'ai pris des cernes ma
barbe a blanchi sous l'effet de
peut-être du stress et sans doute de son
impact sur mon métabolisme je vous
confirme que je suis atteint d'une
maladie qui s'appelle le vitiligo qui
n'est ni douloureuse ni contagieuse mais
qui est très visible et encore pour moi
elle l'est moins que pour d'autres bon
voila moi j'ai une barbe qui a une drôle
de drôles de couleur c'est comme ça
c'est pas un sujet c'est je n'assume et
j'ai pas besoin de m'en excuser c'est
comme ça dans le milieu politique on
l'appelle centre deuxième des siens ah
ouais et dans le milieu du
tabac je suis à 100% d'accord avec kelly
et valérie je trouve que là il a un
siège intéressant c'est qu'en fait il
n'est pas du tout dans l'hystérie
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres gens
aujourd'hui ça mais là c'est normal il a
rien à tout est assez normal et
il ya la plaque à jouer qui malgré tout
sont dans l'ain sud dans l'affectif dans
les repérages dans l'hystérie et je
trouve que lui justement il prend et
construit petit à petit une posture de
chef d'état et je trouve que c'est
intéressant et pardon matches étaient
très bien renseignés
mais elle veut y aller pour une seule
raison c'est qu'elle est déjà entre à
négocier avec macron de faire perdre
bertrand pour pouvoir avoir un poste
chez schéma qu'on dise je le sais
parce que je connais des gens bien me
placer lors des milieux bien placé qui
sont bien placés
vif et tu sais que tu parles présenter
les anges pendant 4
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais il y avait déjà eu il ya des mecs
qui ont fait de la politique dont les
enjeux à l'escherichia fait mal sa chute